je m'appelle Daniel Lugo et je crois que le
rêve américain tout cela a commencé parce qu'il
était temps de me pousser plus fort sinon
je regardais encore 40 ans quand je faisais de la
survêtement pour travailler c'est un gars plutôt décent
qui travaille dur mais il est un
peu  dans une ornière vous travaillez dur et qu'est
-ce que la vie vous sert un sandwich honteux il
est inspiré pour aller là-bas et faire
bouger les choses et devenir un acteur dites que
vous aimeriez que vous vouliez le chasser le dépecer
et monter sa tête sur votre mur
malheureusement  sa méthode de travail n'est
pas intelligente je suis un self-made man j'ai
gagné beaucoup d'argent
qui ont tous ces trucs qui
ne l'apprécient vraiment pas ou ne le méritent pas ce qui se
passe cher c'était juste fatigué d'
être là où tu es Adrian
j'aime bien ça ici je veux dire réveillé pour midi je
veux dire quand les souris et une fois que je t'ai  payé
à Brett ce qu'il faisait j'ai un plan pour
changer qu'ils ont fait un th  troisième personne qui
allait adhérer à ce plan parce que
si vous y réfléchissez, c'est un
plan insensé, vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas prendre les affaires d'un mec,
mais c'est sûrement un criminel J'ai
regardé beaucoup de films Paul je sais ce que je
fais  est une histoire vraie, folle, absurdement comique,
hardcore, nous avons de vrais
gars pros qui viennent jouer le rôle
et ils apportent tous
c'est un film à gros budget, vous ne pouvez pas le
téléphoner dans la tête un film de Michael Bay que
vous devez apporter  votre jeu A tout le
temps Michael essayant de faire quelque chose d'
extrêmement différent les gens seront
vraiment surpris de voir à quel point il est bon dans la
comédie je dois avoir une marionnette bien sûr ça
fait mal je sais que ça le fait